comment est ce qu'on écrit maman khalifa
et
elle s'appelle monique à maman a rougi
tuer mais qui est venu avec toi là
ça fait longtemps que même en sus on
pousse j'ai eu l'impression que d'amer
sucer son pouce pendant que tu chantais
en juin elle avait un doigt dans la
bouche elle faisait causa faudra lui
diop
ah bon massés sur les noms c'est très
grave alors on donne une maman travaille
on travaille à la mine afin que c'est du
travail à la maison parce que 10 dont il
faut faire les lits faut vous faire
laver intitulé d'un petit peu il m'a
jamais aimé youri ils l'obligent à la
basse côte c'est tout c'est tout le
monde peut replier et tu pourrais
l'aider un petit peu